Well, those are the diagrams types. I just wanted to repeat that
no particular system that you develop is going to use all of them. And, in fact,
you're probably going to concentrate on the most popular ones. But
they're there in case you need them.
I also want to mention two other features of UML that don't involve diagrams.
[COUGH] One is the Object Constraint Language and the other one,
I hinted tthat a few minutes ago, the Metamodel. The Object Constraint Language,
and we'll devote a whole lesson to this, is a textual extension to UML's vis,
visual notation. Its purpose is to provide a more precise specification,
to be able to specify things which you can't specify in the diagrams themselves.
You can use this textural extension as annotations to class model diagrams,
and statechart diagrams. Essentially, the Object Constraint Language,
this first-order predicate logic, plus the ability to navigate around
the diagrams and some collection classes, like sets and, and bags and sequences.
The overall purpose of the Constraint Language, Object Constraint Language,
is to be very precise, if you need to, in the specifications of your system.